[Music]
God exists name is petronia della
signora de onís toga meet em
[Music]
it is about woman defying the system and
winning this film this is a true story
I am an actual woman five years ago jump
for the cross called the cross and well
her life became impossible because
everybody said you are a woman we don't
have the right to jump when we heard
this story me and my sister five years
ago we saw an opportunity to speak about
everything that frustrates us as women
living in the Balkans Damaris parish
Peggy private quick run
it is a feminist film feminism must
include men also the strife of Justice
of petronia is something that any woman
all men can identify with crystal meth
neon will travel beyond freakazoo
the 19th of January a young woman jumped
in the water in slip and the priest gave
the cross without any problem this is
due to the courage of this individual
five years ago who did an incredibly
courageous thing and who knows from next
year many more women will jump for the
cross and yes also me
[Music]
you